[Music]
the no social media so
found a gq piece
on you and digital minimalism
and
you mentioned that you had tech company
during the com
bubble
and you've joked that
you originally didn't sign up for
facebook
because maybe there's i'll just read the
quote
there was probably a little bit of petty
jealousy newport says like oh why is
this company so popular i'm not going to
give him the satisfaction of using his
products so did you
commit is that just purely in jester did
you early on commit to that
and then it just worked for you so you
continued in other words was it like a
first principles decision or did it
start off in a different way
through the sands of time
i'm trying to remember because i had to
go back and do some research and i i did
confirm that
facebook arrived at my college in 2004
and i confirmed that was true
and that was the first major there's
things before that there's friendster et
cetera but those were more niche like
there wasn't a real pressure to sign up
for those right my memory and again this
is through the santa time is that there
was two factors why i didn't sign up for
facebook one was just what you were
talking about so mark zuckerberg was a
contemporary of mine
he was a computer science student at
harvard at the time that i was a
computer science student at dartmouth we
had both started companies around the
same time his has been a little bit more
successful so i think
facebook ended up a little bit more
successful than princeton web solutions
which is what which is what i had been
running i mean you know comparable
if you just add seven zeros
so there was some of that because
like especially i remember like all the
women i knew and they were like oh this
is so fun i want to be on there like why
are they interested in this guy's
service there's some of that the other
thing and i think this is true because i
have a really strong memory of this
i have a weird it's not a phobia but um
an inability
to do rank list right so if you ask me
hey what's your favorite book
which i get asked on podcast i don't
know how to answer it if you say what's
your two favorite movies i can't it's uh
there's there's probably a name for it
our rapid fire questions are going to be
great towards the end of this
you'll see you'll see all three i freeze
on these all the time or if i know
they're coming like i've done this
recline show a few times i learned like
sorry sorry you're cutting out i'm sorry
what was that yeah your connection's
really bad they're all great it's like
enumeration and numeracy if i'm going to
invent the word and that was what early
facebook was was you would your profile
was a favorite quote favorite movies
favorite books it was a lot of irving
goffman presentation of self type
sociology you had to decide like what am
i going to say my favorite movie is my
favorite quote to try to create a
presentation itself that was and i can't
do that like i can't so i really
remember it's a combination of those two
things i was like now this isn't for me
and i got to tell you all it took was a
few years of separation
that suddenly i felt like margaret mead
among the polynesian islands because i
was the only person not using this and
it was so interesting like from a remove
it was like really interesting and i was
like okay i think i'm just gonna run
with this for a while and
i gotta tell you from the outside
it seemed more and more absurd not that
the services seemed absurd in isolation
the thing that seemed absurd my memory
was this presumption of universality
that these are technologies that
everyone has to use and it's weird if
you don't i thought they seemed kind of
niche like they're kind of cool and if
you're in the technology or web 2.0
maybe it's interesting i had nothing
against them but i was really wary about
this rising presumption that everyone
has to use it and i know i'm an internet
nerd from the early days and i'm like i
don't know that we should consolidate
the internet into two or three companies
where they built their own private
shadow version of the internet that they
control we already have the internet do
we have to use these private wild garden
versions of the internet and and this
idea that it was weird not to use it
that's really the thing that got to me
after that was the thing that really
probably made me an advocate
in the skeptical calm among social media
was not that i thought what was
happening on twitter was bad
um it was
why is it such a big deal that i don't
use it that's that's really what what
pushed me into a place of you know
something weird is going on in our
culture
you